somebody domesticated them and who's
that somebody it's obviously
[Music]
themselves so now I'm going to little do
a shift here and uh and talk about what
we know about the evolution of reduced
reactive aggression the reduced
propensity to lose your Tempo when
somebody insults your mother and I'm
introducing the famous experiment by the
um Russian biologist Dimitri BF who in
the 1950s started
selecting
foxes on the basis of reduced reactive
aggression so here's what he did he took
foxes just like uh you know the red
foxes here that there slightly Black
version that occurred in in
Canada uh they'd been in Russia for 50
years breeding without anyone
deliberately um selecting them and so
what BF did was to arrange for people to
walk towards the young foxes when they
were something like 6 weeks old and uh
at the point that the young fox
said then they would write down well how
far was that and they would breed from
the ones who got closest who who allowed
the human to get closest and within a
few years in sometimes three years
sometimes 5 years sometimes 10 years
different aspects of features that are
found in domesticated animals
suddenly appeared such as these white
patches doesn't look much like a fox
anymore does it looks like
pho floppy ears you probably remember
that there's only one animal in the wild
that has floppy ears or one kind and
that's elephants floppy ears are
characteristic of our friendliest dogs
so these are examples of features of the
domestication syndrome and what we're
seeing here is evidence that you select
against reactive aggression and then
boom magic you you get these features of
the domestication syndrome which is why
goats and horses and cows and cats and
dogs all have individuals that have got
white patches of fur on them and floppy
ears occur in all of these animals
too so that was a remarkable Discovery
and it means we can now reverse engineer
as it were and go backwards and say okay
if you show self domestication syndrome
or if you show a domestication syndrome
that means that there was selection
against active
aggression and fascinatingly Homo
sapiens that's you and me most of us
anyway I think
here has key features of domesticated
species as determined by archaeologists
so archaeologists working in the range
of say 5 to 10,000 years quite often
find an animal animal bones and they
want to know was this a domesticated
species or was it a wild version was it
a wolf or was it already a dog by this
time so they look at the bones and they
say well okay how do we tell and here's
how they tell lighter body shorter face
smaller teeth feminization of the skull
and skeleton and uh brain reduction and
guess what Homo sapiens shows all of
these features in relationship to our
earlier ancestors they don't all emerge
at the same time short face and small
teeth are some of the things that happen
the very earliest moment brain reduction
only in the last 30,000 years but it's
an amazing thought that our brains are
about 10 to 14% smaller than
uh though those of our ancestors 30,000
years
ago and then these these domestication
like traits and there are special ones
in humans uh increase through time so
the the brow Ridge is getting lighter as
we come closer to the Future any big
brown ridges you um and the face gets
narrower and in some of these cases we
don't actually know what this means in
terms of aggression this is totally
amazing so this is a player picture of
people playing hockey that is ice hockey
which is what they they call hockey in
the states and um uh this guy has had
his his head measured so uh to look at
the width of the face in relationship to
the the length of the face or the height
of the face and the reason we're we're
looking at hockey players is because in
hockey if you get into a fight then the
ref puts you into the Penalty Box so you
can ask well how long people spend in
the box in relationship to the width of
their face and the answer is that the
wider your face then the more time you
spend in The Penalty Box and it doesn't
seem likely that there are sort of some
subtle biases that have caused people to
uh to have that relationship and I want
to point out that none of these
relationships is is individually
statistically significant but this is
six different teams of professional
players in which uh the trend is there
and if you look at college players you
get the exactly the same thing thing
that it's not individually significant
but uh in in each team it would be if
you did it for long enough but it is
always consistent and this is one of an
example of many different um studies
looking at the relationship between
facial width in men and aggressiveness
dominance um and uh motivation to
succeed and and there are now investment
firms that are glommed onto this and
realized that you get invest different
investment strategies by men according
to the breadth of their face and they're
now dealing with the ethical problems of
uh of how to uh build that into the
assignments and so
on um okay third point so so the second
point was that we got these features
that are characteristic of sapiens that
have increasingly uh increased over time
the domestication features and we can
compare with various other species of
homo and Homo sapiens is the only one
that has these domestication features so
for instance the breadth of the face uh
here it is in neander tals wider than in
humans and here it is in denans the
Asian uh populations of of homo where
they've had to reconstruct it based on
the genes U which are they understand
quite a lot about the way that
methylation of genes is associated with
u the breadth of the
face so you might think then that we
could start looking at the genetics and
see whether or not we share the Gen
genes for domestication with animals and
it turns out that we do so people are
beginning to get the domestication genes
sorted out you know you all these
similarities in different domesticated
lines such as the white patches and the
floppy ears I mentioned and so you think
there should be some some commonality in
the genes and uh when you look at the
differences between uh dogs and wolves
uh then it turns out that some of those
are in common genetically with the
differences between domesticated horses
and the Wilder horses same with cats and
cows and then you take all of those
genes you say okay are they similar to
the differences between sapiens and
Neals or denans and the answer is yes
are the domestica genes that we have in
common with these domesticated animals
are not found in the neales and denans
so that means that prior to this sort of
time half to almost a quarter of a
million years ago which is when we split
with Neals and denans there would have
been something different going on
genetically so what this suggests is
that in Homo sapiens we've had selection
against reactive aggression which is not
applied to these other species that
don't show any evidence of domestication
or loss of reactive aggression and I'm
now going to draw your attention to what
happens to uh alpha
males
okay so the summary of the section we
just looked at here is that um if you
think about the time since 4 million
years ago up to the
present Homo sapiens emerges something
like 300,000 years ago the very earliest
intimations of it from fossils in
Morocco and the differences that we see
there are like those found in
domesticated animals and that means
somebody domesticated them and who's
that somebody it's obviously themselves
so it's what we call self-domestication
so why did it happen how come we're all
such wonderfully self-domestication and
polite individuals that nobody's had a
fight in here yet well
done okay so low reactive aggression
according to the Bone evidence and the
tooth evidence and the genetic
evidence began around 300,000 years ago
or was manifest by then so why did it
happen
happen so all non-human
primates have a thing called alpha males
and you might think that we do but I'm
going to argue that we
don't so the alpha is a male who is on
top of the hierarchy the dominance
hierarchy of fighting ability and he
uses his reactive aggression which we've
already seen is a lot more elevated than
in humans to respond to any
challenges and that really works well
because
maintains his position as the alpha male
and guess what he ends up evolutionarily
successful because all alpha males tend
to do very well in terms of the critical
currency of evolution High paternity
fathering lots of kids so this is true
for chimpanzees it's true for gorillas
and it's true for
bonobos I'm going to say that homo
sapiens does not have alpha males
because the leaders let's call them
leaders not Alphas they lead by
consensus I Donald Trump cannot
personally bring down in a barroom fight
uh all the people that he wants to to
dominate he relies on having
supporters and that is true for all
human groups uh it means that uh the um
actual leader uh need not be the
dominant gender in the group so we can
have women who can be
uh leaders uh we can have uh all sorts
of people you know three-year-old boys
being leaders um so the important thing
is that they are not fighting in terms
of uh their own personal ability to
dominate others one on one all right so
somehow we lost alpha males and my
question now is what is it that's
selected against being an alpha male
it's not an easy problem to answer
because we've seen alpha males get
evolutionary benefit by being an alpha
male they dominate access to the
paternity that doesn't happen with our
leaders thank
God nowadays if you have somebody who is
seriously violent then we have ways of
dealing with them using a sort of
somewhat chimpanzee like system of an
imbalance of power so you know five
policemen come to your door and carry
you away but what they do with you is
take you to a
prison and we have to think ourselves
back to a time when prisons did not
exist then what did you do about someone
who was seriously violent and the answer
is you executed them to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit I a.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest
ideas